foreign
let's go out to uh Heather in Reno
Heather what's going on
um so my question is am I wrong for
wanting to end my engagement because my
fiance doesn't want to get a job and
also wants me to move in to his great
uncle's house with him after getting
married
no end it this is the easiest call of my
entire show whatever
yes and why are you even asking the
question
I don't know I just thought maybe there
was something else I could be doing
so that we could move forward he doesn't
want to move forward with you
okay
um right
I guess so yeah have you told them I'm
not gonna marry you unless you have a
job or I'm not going to marry you if
your plan for housing is that we move in
with my uncle
yeah I did give him in February I gave
him the boundary that if by the end of
March he didn't have a job or start
therapy that I didn't really think I
could see myself continuing the
relationship so I want I want to flip
around it's more of an ultimatum than a
boundary but I want to flip your
ultimatum around
good for you you drew a line in the sand
and said this is where me and my values
stop
and he chose to not marry you
I don't want you wearing around I don't
want you being a martyr here like I had
to end this thing because I I
you were strong and brave and very clear
here is my standards for somebody that
I'm going to Hitch my wagon to
and someone's gonna hitch their wagon to
me and that we're going to do life
together forever
come hell or high water here's my line
and he said I don't want that I'm out
yeah
um just to go back
um
to give more detail into this his uncle
did start having some health problems in
the middle of February okay
um and so
he felt responsibility to take care of
him
and so I tried being supportive and
understanding like I did really want to
support him and his family
through this hard time but
um
I just didn't really feel like a
priority
um and so I'm kind of like
I feel selfish because I'm like why I
almost feel like I'm making him choose
between me and
his family
hmm
why won't he get a job
because he says that he needs to take
care of his uncle
obviously have money for food
his uncle helps provide financially
so what about
another reason why he wanted us to live
with his uncle because we wouldn't have
to be
um we wouldn't have the financial burden
of rent
oh
foreign
why do you think so little about what
you want and so little about what you
need
I don't know I want to say because I
love him and
I do want I do see a future with him but
he doesn't see one with you
because here's what I think I think that
before this happened in February
I think he didn't work either
yeah and I think before this happened in
February he was kind of a freeloader
anyway
and before this happened in February you
were already thinking I I can't just
I love you we've had some great fun
times together
but I can't I can't commit myself for
the rest of my life
to somebody who has so little drive so
little desire to hear what I need and to
help meet my needs
um
I I think you know that going in I don't
think you're selfish
yeah
this would be totally different if he
was going to law school or he's in year
three of a computer science degree or
he's already working as a as a as a
like a plumbing apprentice and he was
making some money and he had plans for
getting a good job and whatever and then
all of a sudden a bomb dropped in his
family and he had to stop what he was
doing to go care for somebody that's
Noble that's incredible and that happens
a lot and I have a feeling that if that
were the case you'd be all in
yeah
am I is that is that right
yeah yeah definitely I would be like yes
I will support you like I'm here for you
so has he always since you've known him
been a fun
whatever guy blah blah blah so cute all
that stuff but he's also been kind of
lazy
uh yeah I would I don't know if I
was like in him and that was hard to
um
hard to swallow because I like I really
like
have I have goals and I want to grow and
change and
um sometimes it just felt like he was
really okay with being
in the same exact spot
in his life how old are you
I'm sorry that your heart's broken
yeah
I'm sorry
because I don't really know like what
else I can do other than I'm gonna tell
you nothing zero things
okay
there's there's nothing there's not a
conversation you haven't magically said
there's not a thing you haven't like oh
maybe if I just wear the not nothing
yeah you heard me say this a million
times behavior is a language
and so yeah he may not be saying it but
what he's saying with through the way
his actions are
is I'm gonna take the easiest Road out
for me at any given moment
and right as you told him here's your
ultimatum uncle got sick and he's like
oh that'll solve all of our problems
yeah
and you can see the short-term thinking
this will just get us this will cover
our rent and this will cover our food
yeah there's nothing about what his
career going to look like what is 10
years from now what is our family
situation going to look like where would
kids live I mean none of that it's very
short-term very egocentric very childish
thinking
okay right
yeah
and I'm heartbroken for you because I
know you I know you love this kid
yeah
and you wish he was the guy that would
be your guy and I'm hearing you say he's
not
yeah I guess the One Shining Light in
the dark here is that you're not married
and you don't have two kids and you're
just now coming to this realization
yeah I just
it got to the point where
I felt like I was going into the
marriage knowing it was going to end in
divorce
and I just didn't
I I can't tell you how proud of you I am
most people don't have the courage to
as I say all the time turn the lights on
turn the music off and say what are we
doing
stop the party we got somebody's off the
train because I'm getting off I just
gotta stop for a second
and that's not to say that
um
two years from now that he doesn't call
you and be like hey man I'm I was
immature little brat and here I am now
I'm doing this and this and this and
yeah he can take you for we can I take
you for coffee that kind of thing right
that's how the movie would end right
um
that's that's not saying that's not
gonna happen what I'm saying here is
I stand behind you 100 Heather
well you know deep in your bones which
you know through experience what you
know that you want when you look out and
say this is the kind of relationship I
want to have it's the kind of marriage I
want to have this is the kind of life I
want to have
you know you've got a very clear Lane a
clear picture of what that looks like
what you're telling me is he's not it
huh
and you're going to spend a season and
heartbreak and a season in grief and a
season and sadness and that's okay
that's right
but don't compromise your values and
don't compromise who you are and don't
compromise who you want to become and
who you're becoming
just because it's uncomfortable and hard
right now
I'm proud of you for sticking to your
guns
if I can never help holler at me thank
you so much for the call